the museum is owned by the south of
Museum and Art Gallery transport now
that's an independent organization it's
not the whole do anyone council but the
transport does have a management
contract with the Invercargill City
Council so we contract out to ICC to run
the day-to-day operations of the museum
on air behalf well it's been about 25
years since the last redevelopment
project for the museum it was officially
opened in 1990 and since then we've
collected quite a few more items so
we're desperately in need of storage
space for them
the museum has a collection of about
seventy one thousand items and there
will stored away on the second floor of
the pyramid probably locked up about as
tight as a bank vault at the moment they
kept safe and secure because there's
quite a valuable collection there it's
insured for about ten million dollars
but we don't really know what the true
value of any particular item is they are
mostly single items and they're
unreplaceable so up in the top store
everything is completely fall you can
see here for instance that we've got
shelving that's three shelves high we'd
really like to get those up to five high
so that we can get more material stored
in the same space you can see also that
we've got items on air corridors and so
on that's just the fact that everything
is full and we run out of space here's
an example of items in the store which
are stacked on top of each other these
boxes here cartoons here actually
sitting on a table which is part of the
collection as well we need to get these
into shelving which is four to five
shelves and maybe three to four meters
high just to improve the storage
capability this is another issue in the
top store the collection store the space
we currently use as the registrar's work
area now this is in the store and it
really should be moved outside but we
don't have any space to put this at the
moment the reason is that it's called in
here but also that the work that carried
out here can create dust and fumes if
any conservation work is being done so
these sort of operations need to be
taken away from this space and put
somewhere else in the space that's
developed in the building here's some of
their Natural History Collection these
taxidermied items as you will see not
only covered and plastic but there's
other plastic bags over top of them
early taxidermy relied on things like
arsenic to prevent deterioration of the
specimens this table is a nice piece of
furniture but it actually has a sad
history this was made out of timber that
was recovered from the wreck of the SST
Aurora which found
on the reef down at my paper point with
the loss of 121 lives that's actually
been made out of timber that was
recovered off the beach and it has a wee
plaque on it saying how was made in
remembrance of the people who died there
so one of the issues we find is that in
the foyer of the museum is people come
in the front door they met with a lot of
visual clutter on one side we have the
reception desk and the shop on the other
side we have the eyesight and way down
behind me we have the cafe but it's hard
to actually see we see where you want to
go if you are coming in as a visitor and
down if you turn to the right down
through gallery one that's where you get
to the stairs to go upstairs is also
another steer past the shot but you
can't actually see those visual clues as
to where to go from when you're standing
in the foyer and that's one thing that
we can't solve without redeveloping the
building and total the lift is another
issue in the museum this doorway here
you see is about 1.2 wide and about 1.8
hi it's only about two meters deep we
need a larger left in order to be able
to store larger items in a collection
the Tewa tarian is actually a part of
the air space off gallery to you next
door so it means that you're not
immersed on the atmosphere of the
tuatara we're completely divorced on
them by the glass and by the ceiling
here what we want to do is develop our
new tuatara & Co Coco enclosure which
will be right out on the lawn out in
front of the building here and when you
go into that tuatara enclosure you'll be
in the same atmosphere as the tuatara so
you'd be able to smell and hear what's
what it's like in their enclosure with
the tuatara an iconic part of the south
of museum there are two options that we
have one is that we upgrade where they
stay in the current facility and that
provides us with an issue of where do we
house them during the rebuild there's
also as you're aware probably another
proposal around
kaka poor IAM just alongside the museum
and if that project goes ahead and
that's still under being considered by
the Invercargill city council that
that's their project then there's an
opportunity for us to rehouse the
tuatara and there and that would mean we
wouldn't have to translocate them
anywhere else during the rebuild project
yes there are some issues with
earthquake-prone standards in the
building some of them are below thirty
three percent and we have to bring them
up legally above that we'd like to get
to one hundred percent and there are
also some issues around fire safety the
paneling that that covers the roof of
the pyramids called bond or paneling and
it's basically expanded polystyrene now
back in nineteen ninety that stuff was
state-of-the-art but since then through
a couple of events elsewhere in New
Zealand we've discovered that f-fire
actually gets into the polystyrene then
there's a good chance that it just can't
be put out the fire service have said to
us if the fire gets in there all they
can do is stand back and stop it from
spreading and that's not a good way to
protect you know a priceless collection
of southland heritage the attractions
that we want to develop in the museum
firstly to retain and improve the
exhibitions that we have at the moment
such as the roaring 40s tuatara we also
want to develop some new ones which will
be a new story of sales and exhibition
which will combine aspects of the
current history gallery and also the
Natural History gallery and the Maori
gallery they will come together in one
exhibition that we hope to develop all
about the story of South and and have
the peoples of South underdeveloped from
Maori 32 early European contact and then
up to more modern times so that we can
show people that what goes on in our
area in their community we also want to
improve the tuatara exhibition by
rebuilding that and to do that we'd like
to move it outside the building hence
the idea developed
we have combined that with a possible
kakapo enclosure that was a an idea that
came to us through councilor Karen
Arnold and the Department of
Conservation with the Occupy recovery
project on fen Abajo we also want to
keep the current art gallery exhibition
areas that we have with their community
access gallery and touring exhibition
space but we also want to invite in the
Andersons Park art gallery to join us
here and we think that would be a
positive thing for the gallery and for
the CBD of invercargill the proposed
redevelopment project costing about 43
million dollars does not include the
cost of the proposed kakapo go into a
tire enclosure that's a separate project
and that's estimated at the moment to be
about 1.9 million dollars just under 2
million dollars that will be funded
separately from the museum redevelopment
the reasons for scheduling the work
because it provides opportunities to
solve all the problems that will
actually have when we come to redevelop
this building with all of the storage
and the collection that we have and all
the exhibitions that we have set up at
the moment with objects from the
collection as well we have to remove all
of those from the building before we can
pull off the roof and start redeveloping
the building so we need somewhere else
with him to go that's an extremely
difficult thing to do for a museum
manager because everything is to be
pulled out individually and wrapped and
protect it and then taken to another
storage space which is also climate
controlled so a proposal is that in the
new building that will put to the west
on the old tennis courts will have one
floor in there which will use for
temporary storage of our collection so
after we've built a new building will
move everything in there and the storage
in which it could take two to three four
years to do perhaps
and then after that we will redevelop
the pyramid so it gives us the
opportunity to move everything within
the building without having to take it
outside and then after the parameters
complete we'll move for the eyes of the
collection items back into the storage
area that will create and then it'll be
permanently stored and with the proposed
to a terror and kakapo enclosure will be
shifting at the tuatara as well so then
the building will be the pyramid
building will be free for its
redevelopment one of the things that
we'd like to achieve why we're getting
the redevelopment plans underway as Otto
also to get an increase in our
operational funding but that needs to be
about six hundred thousand dollars a
year so we could employ two more
curators and perhaps two technicians the
way we will propose to do that is
working through our shared services
model where we have the south and
regional Heritage Committee it collects
rates from every household in South
another present that's about
thirty-three dollars fifty this current
year to increase our operational funding
to the amount that really need where we
are suggesting that that thirty-three
dollars fifty needs to be increased by
another twenty dollars per annum per
every household and salesmen that would
provide more funding to smeg South
Museum and Art Gallery would also
provide more funding to Southland
District Council down nagaur district
council the redevelopment project which
the Trust Board wishes to proceed with
is going to cost about forty three
million dollars in total at present day
dollars we hope to make that more
affordable and also to program the work
into two parts because it's necessary to
do so for practical reasons that the
first part of that work will be about 20
million dollars worth and we had hoped
to proceed with that in about one half
years time that'll take maybe three
years to construct
and then we would operate the two parts
of the building together the new and the
old and the existing pyramid for about
perhaps three to five years and then we
would spend the twenty three million
dollars to redevelop the pyramid so that
would make a 43 million in total our aim
with this project is to end up with a
facility that fosters heritage culture
arts and education something that south
and can be really proud of
at the time table for carrying out this
project is over an extended period of
time up until the end of this year we
expect to spend their time publicizing
what the transport wishes to do with the
redevelopment and make sure that the
community are happy with what we're
planning to do on board with it after
that we'll get underway with grant
applications and we'll also need to then
once we have some verification that the
funding will fall into place we would
get on to detail design work which we
could be about nine months of that to be
done before we could actually start
tendering and construction work so we'd
expect perhaps that the construction of
the first phase of the rebuilding would
start and about twenty seventeen as far
as the operational funding goes that
would need to we would think get into
the annual plans for the territorial
authorities probably in July next year
for the annual plan so it would need to
be getting information to the district
councils by februari or march next year
in order to get into their annual plans
the construction of phase one will take
about three years so that's going to be
probably about twenty seventeen to
twenty nineteen and then bringing in the
Andersons park at gallery if that
suggestion comes off that would be
occurring during 2020 so the art gallery
would open in 2020 if we have say about
five years of operation and relocation
of the collection after that we were
then start construction of Phase two
about 20 24 something of that time 24 to
25 pets and will be about two years of
construction and one year of building
exhibitions before that the pyramid
would reopen so we would expect
the pyramid reopened about 20 27 and
then we'll have maybe a year or so when
the collection was being moved from the
new building back into the pyramid so
that may be finished about the end of
2029 so we're talking quite a period of
time that long-term plan but well worth
doing